and finally new rule I want to believe
representative Vance McAllister the
congressman who was caught on tape last
year passionately kissing a staffer when
he says he's a new man and quote blessed
with a great family and a wonderful
Christian wife but first he has to take
his hand off her
ass you know we don't ask a lot here in
America of our Representatives but last
month Politico ran a story on the
midterms entitled good election year for
the bad boys of Congress which detailed
how even Scandal plagued Lo lives are
nonetheless cruising to reelection I
mean look at this his tongue is forming
exploratory
committee that's not kissing that's
[Applause]
fracking and this guy ran on being a
family values Christian no wonder that
when this story broke he quit who could
recover from hypocrisy that blatant but
now he's back in because he remembered
something oh yeah I live in America no
one's paying
attention same thing with the
Appalachian trails most famous hiker
former South Carolina Governor Mark
Sanford another Born Again booty
caller who left office in disgrace but
who's back because he realized that in
Kardashian America name recognition is
all that matters Michael Grim
Michael Grim leads in the polls in his
Staten Island District despite being
under indictment for 20 counts of fraud
that's a lot of fraud even for Staten
Island and then there's my favorite
Tennessee Scott dejarle a pro-life
champion who encouraged his ex-wife to
have two
abortions and talked one of his
Mistresses into having another one more
he gets a free latte
this guy walks into Planned Parenthood
everyone goes
norm
and he's a doctor who's also at affairs
with at least two of his patients
somewhere Anthony Weiner is thinking but
texting a picture of my dick was too
much usually when a doctor his
patients that much it's over the bill
[Applause]
and still he's looking forward to a
third term which is more than I could
say for the fetuses he
conceives oh you'll get over it
D
Dam
my if he wasn't actually up for the
third term I wouldn't do the joke but it
was too
perfect my question is who do you have
to blow to get thrown out of
Congress
as a political science experiment I
would like to see a member of Congress
kill
someone on live TV just to see if they'd
get voted out for it really let's have a
congressman commit cold-blooded murder
on camera then get up and say uh yes
I've made
mistakes I killed a Drifter just to
arouse myself sexually but the election
isn't about killing Drifters it's about
working families with my wife Jenny on
one side and Jesus on the other and he'd
win we need a new definition of insanity
and it's having a congress with an 8%
approval rating and reelecting just
about all of them only 14% of Voters say
Congress has done anything to improve
their lives and yet reporters keep
finding people who voted against
Obamacare but are on Obamacare and love
it and why wouldn't they why wouldn't
they love it they can finally breathe
that a serious health problem W bankrupt
Andor kill them you'd think that would
be the kind of thing people might want
to reward with their vote but you asked
them would you consider voting Democrat
no I'm sticking with the pro-life
Doctor Who impregnates lots of people
who aren't his wife top that
Obamacare